foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS of moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Rachel Cruz number one
best-selling author Ramsay personality
my daughter is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Jennifer's in Phoenix to start off this
hour hi Jennifer how are you
I am just wonderful how are you today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world exactly
um hi Dave I am calling because I had
purchased the 2023 Kia Miro
and have complete buyer's remote and
remorse after I got it so I took it back
and I got a 2019.
now I'm regretting that and I'm about
ready to just stall it give it back I
think it's too late to give it back and
just walk everywhere
how do I get out of all this mess that I
created
I mean is it is it realistic to walk
everywhere Jennifer are you just kind of
being funny
I'm just kind of being funny okay but
you're just tired of the car remorse of
all the decisions you've been making
exactly so how much do you owe on this
car
this new car thirty two thousand okay
and what's your household income
um my household income is 52
000. okay
well your buyer's remorse is logical
because it was a bad decision
so um I agree but your your past the
point of being able to return it because
you've owned it for a while correct
correct that is correct but a couple
weeks and so I'm not sure you're going
to be selling it and likely taking a
loss
likely and then you're going to have to
get something cheap that you can afford
to drive do you have any money
um cash no
do you have like a mutual fund that's
not in retirement or do you have any
money you can get your hands on
no
okay
all right what did you get rid of what
were you driving before
um
I did 2017 Kia Soul that I only owed 12
000 on
yeah that was probably about right with
the idea we were going to turn and get
that paid off
so you were about about where you needed
to be so we need to move back that
direction and there's probably going to
be some Financial pain involved like you
might lose a couple Grand in this move
back towards your old car right
correct and you'll probably finance that
into the deal and um when I do something
stupid and uh Jennifer I've done a lot
of stupid stuff a lot bigger than this
okay uh I always just call when I when
it costs me money I always just say
Dave's paying stupid tax
so I think Jennifer's getting ready to
pay some stupid tax
I believe so you got car fever and
instead of taking a cold shower you
bought a car
exactly yeah you get it yeah wow it's
been there been there I've done it too I
know what it feels like and that's
that's what gives you that bad taste on
the back of your tongue called regret
right mm-hmm exactly so
the good news is
um that you can fix this the bad news is
it's going to hurt and the good news is
you will learn the lesson so thoroughly
you will never do this crap again
oh yes you've already had enough
emotional pain to never do it again
hadn't you
herself Jennifer I mean I know it's for
it's frustrating and you're like oh my
gosh this is going to cost me just like
Dave was just saying but you know but
but it happens right and so don't be
sitting here for months and months and
months just beating yourself up over it
either give yourself some Grace and
learn from it because that's the best I
mean that's really the best thing that
you can do is to say okay I'm never
gonna make that mistake again but what
you're saying Dave though for her today
for her to go yeah sell it sell it and
move down to a ten thousand dollar car
and take a loan out for the for the 10
grand You're Gonna Lose you're going to
take out for the 10 grand and you're
probably gonna be two grand in the hole
on this flip yeah flipping back out of
this because you probably paid retail
for it and you're probably not gonna get
retail for it on the flip so um
somewhere in there and that's the thing
so when I filed bankruptcy Jennifer I
did a whole lot Dumber things than
you've done I was 28 years old
um Rachel's right
um You don't be too hard on yourself but
I I do want to separate two things there
I was not hard on myself
I never said you're stupid the decision
though I did do some stupid stuff yes
and I wanted to be really hard on the
stupid butt decision yep where I never
go back there again but that's different
than being hard on you know carrying
around shame right right conviction is
different than shame conviction is I did
a stupid thing shame is I am stupid
and I am not personally stupid but I
have done some unbelievably stupid
things in my life I'm 62. I've had a lot
of chances at it you know so there you
go all right Brittany's with us in
Birmingham hey Brittany welcome to the
Ramsay show
Hi how are you great how can we help
um I my question is kind of more of a
moral thing than a money thing
um so my husband is 25 and I'm 23. we've
been married for just over a year and
we've recently kind of decided that we
want to start seeing where every penny
of our money goes
um and both of our parents love you
we've grown up you know going to your
classes and reading your books so we
know everything
um and my mother-in-law decided that she
wanted to offer us some advice so we
started to take some of her advice and
then one day she came to us and said I
just want to go ahead and make your
budget
for you and I immediately laughed this
off and I thought this is crazy like I
would not do that I think she's joking
but my husband thought that it was a
really good idea and I that's so sweet
and I begged and pleaded with him to not
let her do this and so I finally got him
to agree for us to work on our budget
together alone and I thought it would be
for our eyes only but in the middle of
us writing down our paychecks like our
bills and things like that he called his
mom and asked her to come over and she
came over to our house and looked at
everything do you hear the helicopter
blades
foreign
yeah yeah and she she came over and she
looked at everything and I on the way
while she was on the way after eating
off I begged and pleaded with him to not
let her come over I cried I was like
please don't do this I wanted to do this
together and he told me that I was
acting like a child and that it was
ridiculous for me to be acting this way
and it was perfectly okay for his mom to
look at our budget who's the child I'm
like oh my God who's the child here he's
the mommy's Boy geez
exactly and I I said this and I told my
parents and my parents are Furious they
were like what is he thinking
um and basically she came over and
looked at everything and he even let her
take it home with her and do it herself
okay so Britney right now you're 100
right
you're not crazy you need to stop this
from happening this is a boundary
violation helicopter Mommy and Mommy's
boy need to learn the idea that the
Bible says leave and cleave you leave
your parents and you cleave to your
spouse that includes you too Brittany
instead of calling your parents yeah
I'll call your mommy and daddy yeah
y'all need a yep a marriage counselor
and duct tape
no absolutely not ask for wisdom
do it yourself thank you Kyle I think
that's a fair we could grab back on this
because she does come back on it this is
a Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author Ramsey personality is my co-host
we're talking with Brittany 23 and 25
years old her mother-in-law inserted
herself into their budgeting process her
mother brought it in her husband a
better mother-in-law inserted herself
too pretty aggressively into the
budgeting process Brittany doesn't think
that's okay we're kind of in agreement
there and
um you know both parents are big fans
and I want to help this young couple
some appropriately some inappropriately
is that about how far we got Brittany
yes okay so where do we stand today
um
so
took the budget home with her and
got a text message and a group chat with
her she had written everything out that
we make and uh said this is what you say
from this paycheck and blah blah blah
and I texted her very nicely and said we
will decide what we do with our money
um and she didn't like that my husband
didn't like that he thought that I was
being rude to her I have suggested
marriage counseling I have suggested
going to counseling and he does not um
he does not believe in that he doesn't
think that that stuff works he refuses
to go so that's not really an option I
am just calling to get some advice to
see
um if I'm crazy for thinking that this
is completely wrong and
um my parents also agree with me they
think that it's absolutely insane and
um yeah so I'm just calling for advice
to see what you have to say
so
when it comes to relationships Brittany
and money what we always find is usually
has to do with there's the problems and
the issues going on within the
relationship it's not about the budget
it's about that your husband didn't
listen to you your husband didn't
respect your opinion shoots you off like
you were a child
and kept bulldozing his way through
right that that that to me yes your
mother-in-law doing the budget all that
that is that's an issue but for me as if
I were you sitting in your position
that's the issue that I that makes me my
feelings are hurt you know sure well
yeah you weren't listened to so uh but
let's let's make sure that you what
Rachel's saying you're getting this your
feelings don't need to be heard at your
mother-in-law anybody hurt at your
husband yeah yes he's the problem she's
the symptom
that's right yeah
so so Brittany what I mean what I I if I
were you guys you've been married less
than right right at a year less than a
year
yes just over a year yep
um
I would find people in his life that you
guys have a really great relationship
with and I don't know if that's friends
it doesn't need to be family
uh I don't know if that's friends I
don't know if there's like a mentor or
someone that he really looks up to but I
would you need someone else speaking
into this versus us sitting here in
Nashville you know we can we can give
you our advice but really to have people
walk with you because he needs to get to
a point of humility uh to be able to to
to say that therapy is not wrong and I
know some people have like this weird
thing about it but to go to go to
marriage counseling uh but to hear other
people speak into his life because I'm
scared that it's like he's so tunnel
visioned into what he wants to do
including bringing his mom into those
situations that you that you're you're
not being heard within your marriage and
so and I want to make sure you're
communicating it well too right that
you're not you know yeah I don't think
you need to text her about this again I
think you need to bust him
yes and I've tried to have that
conversation no no you just blew it off
you're you're there is no excuse for you
to go after her again she's not the
problem
she's the symptom I want you to direct
all of your Force into your marriage
relationship
because that's where all of this is
I have and one met with you're acting
like a child you're being ridiculous
you're being rude yeah I heard you say
that but my point is that doesn't then
then you turn left and go text her
uh which kind of verified what he was
saying
and so instead of going at him
because uh this guy's relationship with
his mom is about three notches too far
over the edge
okay period period anybody listening is
going this is a problem he's a got a
mama's boy syndrome and uh everybody
listening is going yeah this is kind of
obvious you know everybody but him and
his mom and so the good news is this
this young boy has a chance to grow up
and be a man now
and be a husband and uh he's got an
opportunity to step into manhood and the
part of that is uh loving and respecting
your mother as an adult at a bit of a
distance that's right and um with
reasonable boundaries and and listening
to your wife hello and at least like
yeah I don't know that that's my that's
my problem
into your mom and dad y'all are both
acting like your children okay you the
two of you need to take this inside of
your house inside your four walls and
jump on the fact that your relationship
is busted and his respect for you your
all's ability to communicate your
elsibility problem solved without
bringing in outside forces called
in-laws is limited and you need some new
tools to work on that so yeah do you
guys attend a good church by chance
um we don't at the moment I work on
Sundays
um and he works he's on call he's a
lineman so you don't have a good uh
uh pastor's connection that you could
use to just sit down with a pastor
okay that's fair all right then you do
just need to get a hold of a good
marriage counselor or call a good local
Pastor there in Birmingham and just see
if they'll meet with you but um uh you
know no uh you are not being childish
you know you're not being unreasonable
to not want her in there possibly some
of your reactions to the whole situation
once you lost it we're a childish I
don't know about that but um you know
this is a relationship question it is
not a budget question this is a boundary
violation if Sharon Ramsey inserted
herself into Rachel and Winston's uh
Daniel Owens be her son that'd be the
same thing yeah in the Daniel's
situation uh Daniel would not allow that
Allison would not allow that
um and I would not allow her to do that
um so I mean there'd be a lot of not
allowing here it's called Boundaries and
um but for young let's go on I'm the I'm
the guy that teaches America how to do a
budget by the way and I haven't ever
done a budget for any of my grown
married children ever and I remember
coming up to the house Winston I were
probably married about two years and
there was a money thing I can't remember
what it was it was like we had we had
some money and it was like should we
invest it here should we say put it in a
meet like we were it was a pretty basic
question
and you wouldn't answer it you're like
what do you guys think what do you think
what do you think what do you think I'm
like I don't know what to think that's
why I'm asking you should have called
into the show Rachel I should have gone
into the show I would have gotten the
answer I know but but for real though
there's a there's a balance in
overbearing but then young couples
listening to have wisdom speak into your
life yeah she apparently is good at
doing a budget it would have been nice
to have her input so she wasn't
controlling exactly but you can't ask
this woman for anything because she
doesn't know when to stop I know she's
like that Bulldog I had it but never win
this knew when to stop eating so I'd get
fat okay so just cut the food off I'm
thinking about all the young couples
though listening and they've been
married for a year you're you know year
and a half and they don't know maybe
they have questions about their money
and maybe their parents are really great
at money how what what is the
appropriate I think you can ask for help
with that uh and ask for input on
anything and those are good if you're
both good with that number one but
number two if the person you're ass
asking
has reasonable boundaries
and is not going to artificially insert
themselves over the line into the
situation okay now one of the reasons
you got the answer you and Winston got
was uh you're asking me but also you're
asking me in the sense that you you
understand your husband has married into
this family at that time this is what's
going through my head when you're asking
me this question that is uh bigger than
life that takes up all the air in the
room and that everywhere we go it's all
about Dave and it'd be nice for
something to be about Winston and so I'm
like no I'm not getting in this
if it had been a normal situation I
would have answered the question as your
dad but because we're not normal we're
weird you know I Gotta Give I got to
give Winston some space and that's why I
pushed back on y'all I'm like y'all go
figure it out you kind of know the
answer and he already knew the answer
probably but I didn't want him thinking
that he was in my shadow he's the
son-in-law right right you know and
because I got a big old Shadow you know
and so I got to be careful with that
it's just you got to really work this
stuff in your head relationally because
it it man it gets all screwed up fast it
does it's sticky sticky thanks Brittany
for calling good luck yeah work on it
kiddo work on your marriage and your
husband not your mother-in-law this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author my
daughter is my co-host today this is the
Ramsay show Rachel and I and all the
Ramsey personalities just returned from
being gone off and on through the month
of November to different cities from
Sacramento to Minneapolis to San Antonio
and I'm leaving out Phoenix we've been
all over the place and so this last
weekend we were in San Antonio the week
before we were in Minneapolis while I
was in Minneapolis
a guy came up to me during one of the
picture lines we were doing pictures and
signing books with people and all this
stuff handed me this and he said can you
he's a high school teacher teaching our
high school curriculum can you give our
high school a class a shout out oh so
here we go Community Christian School
Wilmer Minnesota Mr Nelson's class
consider yourself shouted Out Mr Nelson
Mr Nelson it's you keeping a sheet of
paper around carry it in my pocket I'm
impressed since since Minneapolis so
there you go look who else is from
Minneapolis I told him I would do it so
I did it and uh well you got it we're
blessed we about 48 of the high schools
in America teach our high school
curriculum now and Mr Nelson and Wilmer
Minnesota is one of them so there you go
on the debt free stage with future weird
people t-shirts on I love it Dane and
Amanda are with us oh also from
Minneapolis
from Mr Nelson's class now not quite not
quite no welcome guys good to have you
all thank you how much debt have you
paid off
254 thousand dollars nice how long does
it take three years three years and your
range of income 190 to 270. okay what do
you guys do for a living I am a
technology recruiter with General Mills
and I'm a pharmacist with the VA in
Minneapolis okay a technology Critter oh
recruiter sorry recruiter
I thought I've got some technology
Critters in the building but we've never
given them that title we've never given
them that title
I've got several as a matter of fact
recruiter I got some of those too yes oh
so it says future weird people so that
means 254 000 and a lot of that was
student loans correct not the house whoa
correct wow big dogs tell us the
breakdown what kind of debt was this
it was credit cards a small portion my
student loans and then his student loans
was the bulk of it and a little bit of
IRS oh pharmacy school
you got it and IRS just like a little
bit attacked it was like the cash flow
during the debt you know you get your
bills so okay good wow so how long you
all been married six years six years
yeah halfway in the marriage you looked
up and went there's a lot of Sallie Mae
in my life yeah tell us a story what
happened well we both kind of had uh
separate I've had at moments uh mine was
uh we just bought a new house we had one
toddler at home another one on the way
um and I just got into my big kid
pharmacist job and we just kept running
we had more month than we had money and
so we'd go into the the credit card we'd
swipe the credit card
um and this was this endless cycle of
trying to pay off the credit card
um and with the second one on the way it
was just it was just scary
um not knowing where our money was going
uh and then for Amanda uh summer 2019 we
had a an opportunity to buy uh
potentially by a lake lot next to her
parents uh cabin on the lake and uh we
were sitting in the boat on the lake
talking and we looked and did the math
and we're like we're almost three
quarters of a million dollar in debt
between our house and our student loans
and this would put us close to a million
and that was a really scary thought so
um our friends Mikey and Caitlin
actually ended up posting on on Facebook
about their Journey we had never heard
your your name before then and they
posted and Amanda reached out to him and
they came over and walked us through it
and that was where we started wow okay
so the you went three quarter of a
million Lake lot no go correct no go
correct my parents were really
supportive and said like this cabin is
basically yours as well so my brother
bought the next lot instead
family
worked out good good wow and now you're
free three years later
yeah okay so so three years ago when you
sat down with that couple and you got
you guys and you're thinking we're gonna
do this
was the journey harder was it easier was
it what you expected walk me through the
last three years it was a lot harder
than we thought
um Dave and this whole show really
supported us
um we thought oh just my loans and our
credit card like the pslf will pay off
Danes that like haha and then a year and
after that we were like okay it's one
percent less than that of people getting
it paid off like we we have to do it
like you went to school we're going to
pay off your debt and
um so really the last like two years
were paying off his debt and we had
another baby
um we were in weddings we said no to a
lot of things that are extra
um yeah on the photo right there too
we'll talk about our biggest cheerleader
his sister
um but when kovid hit too as a
pharmacist I mean he picked up that over
time and I was home with the kids and it
was really stressful and hard on our
marriage him being gone and working so
much but it was still a thank you for
helping everybody and helping our fam
family ultimately like coming home
knowing okay that extra overtime is
going to get us faster and faster so
pick up those shifts like fine we cannot
do things and I'll stay home with the
kids and find something to do but it was
really hard and now that it's like oh I
don't have to pick it up and he got
promoted in the meantime I got promoted
like our salary my salary doubled during
our journey so it was really awesome and
we've had a lot of support very cool
very cool congratulations thank you
thank you proud of y'all thank you so
his sister was one of the big
cheerleaders the people the people you
met from Facebook were big children yes
Something Good Can Come of Facebook we
just write one of the few things yeah
who knew I know and we actually just
last week saw all of you and we went
with Caitlin and Mikey so it was just a
really like oh yeah
you're in Minneapolis yeah without
Caitlyn and Mikey on the video right
there and it was like a really emotional
like full circle like we submitted our
payment it went through like within
those last couple of days
oh my God
good for y'all well done very well done
okay what do you telling people the
secret to getting out of debt is
communication 100 I mean it changed our
changed our marriage communicating about
the money um and then obviously the
budget so I mean we're always talking
about the budget even spending an extra
20 here or there it's like hey can we do
this should we do this
um and it's been huge for us
yeah very much we like feel really weird
when couples say like I'm gonna put it
on my card so my husband doesn't see it
or that I was like I asked him if I can
spend five dollars at Starbucks like I
don't get it and he asks you yes yes
exactly we can talk about it because
that's a lot of people's you know that's
all that's a friction point for a lot of
people is they're like I still want this
level of Independence but you guys are
saying we went all in together working
as a team and and it helped our marriage
right the communication about money and
so that's just encouragement to couples
out there that think oh we there's like
the sense of security that people have
to separate it yes but when you come
together and actually lock arms it's
amazing what it can do yeah it's been so
free
if you don't have that communication and
you're working bazillion hours of
overtime and she's stuck home with the
kids and kovitz afraid you're going to
die from Cove at all in the middle of it
and all that you'd be going into orbit
it was already tough with communication
yeah hard on your marriage you said you
know it was a tough time yeah the only
way you get through that is this
increase we're going to talk about
everything we're gonna talk about
everything we're gonna walk it out we're
gonna walk it out and uh you guys are
impressive well done thank you that's a
great job done a couple of studs well
done good stuff good stuff man good we
got a copy of we got the live and give
bundle for you a copy of Total Money
Makeover to give to a friend maybe jump
on Facebook find somebody to give it to
oh we will baby steps millionaires
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure our latest number one best
seller and a one-year membership to
Financial Peace University use or give
any of that uh it's all there for you
guys just to say we're proud of you and
thanks for making a trip all the way to
Nashville from Minneapolis to do a debt
free scream thank you so much Dane and
Amanda Annapolis 254
000 paid off that includes pharmacy
school then in three years making 190 to
270 right in the middle of a pandemic
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen wow
don't tell me you can't do it if you
went to pharmacy school no whining Dane
and Amanda just did a mic drop on your
idea this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in case you couldn't tell debt-free
screams are a big deal around here folks
who stand on this stage for Heroes they
chose to live like no one else and now
they get to live and give like no one
else that's why we've started giving
everyone who does or that free Scream
the live and give box you just heard me
talking about it it's the tool kit to
walk out this whole baby steps journey
and live and give like no one else the
rest of your life and now it's not just
for debt-free screamers we're offering
the live and give box to all of you you
get a copy of The Total Money Makeover
an entire year of Financial Peace
University and the baby steps
millionaires all for just 99 now
Financial Peace University is 99 so
basically you're getting the two books
free if you want to look at it that way
if you're brand new to the baby steps
these tools the tools in this box will
help you get out of debt and build
wealth or if you're debt free and you're
on your way to being a baby steps
millionaire this is how you can split
the Box up and live and give and make it
into three different gifts if you want
to it's a good deal
so to get to live and give box go to
ramsesolutions.com box
ramseysolutions.com box our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself whyblinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Casey in Arizona
this is going to sound so silly how
strict would you get with this with this
debt payoff we are twenty thousand
dollars in debt with cars we recently
got married I am now pregnant and my
husband refuses to buy me any soup he
wants us living off rice and chicken I'm
puking all day camp keep food this is
real for soup yesterday this is real he
makes very good money so so one can of
soup wouldn't hurt but he's also dead
set on not eating or buy buying anything
other than Essentials we're literally
fighting over it thanks a pregnant wife
Cravings it was that real y'all
see these this is the problem with our
job safe that we've created means we
will have a job that we've created him
him oh no Casey yes no we did not create
him we never told someone ever if you
mean when we say live on beans and rice
rice and beans if you think we mean that
literally I mean you really need to go
back to school it's a metaphor for
sacrifice sacrificial living the deeper
you sacrifice the faster you get out the
chances when we were dead dog broke in
bankruptcy court and my wife is carrying
Rachel during that moment Rachel was
born the year we filed bankruptcy the
chances of me telling Sharon Ramsey she
ain't gonna have any soup is about zero
okay I would have woke up dead
I wouldn't have woke up at all I'm
telling you duct tape to the bed and her
standing over me with a baseball bat it
wouldn't I mean this would not have
worked right we are not going to do this
so come on man come on man I mean really
goodness gracious now coughing well I
just remember how sick I was you were
sick pregnant and like that's so
terrible Casey go get soup go spend ten
dollars each ten cans of soup tell Mr
Pharisee lighten up a notch goodness
gracious okay no we're not buying a new
car we're buying a can of soup
jeez no I don't know I don't know no I
don't know I don't know we're both
Spenders they're hard so we don't I've
had people call and say well I'm in my
husband made me getting a dumpster and
get something out of the dumpster
because you said I never said that ever
never one time that I tell a man to send
his wife to the dumpster to get stuff
out never once but I actually had that
call one time oh my gosh these people
take stuff listen you I get it that you
got the point but you missed the point
okay there's a concept here not a detail
yeah and so it's um
I think it was why Jesus was frustrated
with the Pharisees right oh yeah you got
the concept but you got all caught up in
the details and you went really far over
way over the line down the hole the
rabbit or Casey in Arizona if I had your
address Casey I would ship you a pallet
of soup a pallet yep just show it to the
rest of your pregnancy Costco Costco
here we go direct direct to Casey's yard
uh let's let's do a let's do a GoFundMe
for cases
no she doesn't need that she needs to uh
well she's got it she's got what she
needs now so um
ah
it's kind of low class to just yell at
the top of your lungs I told you so
isn't it well it's one of your favorite
pastimes so go right ahead
um yeah because I got so much crap from
the Bitcoin Bitcoin Bros
and as George says the Bitcoin Bros are
they're pretty much like Mary case
Bitcoin is pretty much like Mary Kay for
young men you know that's what George
says and he's pretty much right because
they don't they can't listen to anything
their brains are turned off if you're
not going to do their thing oh yeah we
got hit on with crypto stuff God man oh
yeah just every time I said don't do
crypto I'm an idiot I'm a boomer I'm out
of touch I don't understand and Dave you
always think you don't like regulation I
would think you don't like I would think
you're like listen I don't like over
regulation when it comes to my money I
do like a wee bit and right now aren't
you wishing you had a wee bit of
Regulation with uh ftx's Sam bankman
fried
I mean there's there's right there in
the name is clue right collapse compared
to Freed I know I know I can't resist
though
the collapse is compared to Enron or
Madoff ftx's failure liking the Enron
scannular Scandal or birdie madoff's
Ponzi scheme uh this from Fox Business
the collapse of cryptocurrency exchange
FTX amid reports that at least one
billion dollars in client funds
disappeared oh my gosh where are The
Regulators well it's not regulated which
some of you were so proud of impacting
potentially around a million customers
has prompted comparisons to some of the
most notorious Financial scandals in
decades yet the magnitude of customers
impacted is even larger FTX which at its
peak was the third largest
cryptocurrency exchange filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy protection on
Friday Told You So and the company
confirmed over the weekend that millions
of dollars worth of assets were
unaccounted for told you so the
company's founder Sam bankman fried
freed faces allegations that he secretly
transferred that's called stealing up to
10 billion dollars from FTX to a mile
amount Imelda research Amita research
Almeida his hedge fund that also filed
for bankruptcy and the company is facing
a criminal probe in the Bahamas
I mean if you can get the bahamians
upset enough about you that they go
after you because they're pretty laid
back Bunch I'm just saying you get them
pissed off you have really stepped in it
wow man he did some like deep deep deep
deep like off of the chain and is it man
yeah and it's just greed I mean like
that's like to the deepest deepest core
oh this is this is now this is just
thievery well yeah yes I know but but
motivation of it it's like yeah but
anybody that doesn't get it I mean it's
the third largest Bitcoin exchange Dave
I mean come on at what point Boomer
aren't you gonna wake up to this new and
shiny wonderful thing you you don't know
what you're talking about tell people to
stay away from this you should I've
already made where's your money now uh
Mr fried took it it is funny though
because crypto it was that it was a Hot
Topic even it's a Hot Topic today I know
but it's all over the news for the last
48 hours it's nowhere this might be the
biggest fraud and theft in human history
I mean if it's bigger than Madoff and
it's bigger so you know the numbers
there uh no it was 68 million or 68
billion or something this is this is
this is they're saying this is going to
be larger yeah yeah it's uh Madoff was
huge though it was massive but um it's
straight up thievery and um and those
millions of people that lost their money
Zippo well sad sad I lost my money on
stupid too
Told You So told you so
oh I'm so I hate that you lost money
guys but I did tell you not to do this
stuff okay I told you well and you can
put a little bit in because I want to be
a little bit of cool I just got a little
bit in because I'm a little bit cool oh
my God I mean I got a friend some
multi-millionaire and he goes Dave I
know but I put ten thousand dollars in
and I'm like dude you could lose that on
the crap table in 30 seconds and not
miss it I know that's why I did it and I
said now you're going to lose it on that
then you're gonna act like you were cool
see it's just yeah yeah I just hate the
spirit around this stuff and what it
does to people because it gets sucked
into it and then they get their heads
taken off and um
this guy slow instead he wins the race
predictable Investments that's the
that's the moral of the story there you
go be the tortoise don't be the uh FTX
hair
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free scream we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Sue is in Chicago hi Sue how
are you
I'm doing great thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um my husband is 62 and I'm 58. we've
been married 38 years we have no debt
and our net worth is a little over a
million
um 200
000 of that is in real estate 800 000 in
stocks and bonds in 1997
um we were raising four little boys and
my husband went through leukemia in a
bone marrow transplant and so the only
life insurance we could get was a whole
life and it was a six hundred thousand
dollar policy
um Dave and Rachel we put in since 1997
uh ten thousand dollars a year into this
policy now what fast forward
um
15 years ago my husband had a heart
attack and five bypasses longevity in
his family the men just historically do
not live long lives so here is our
caveat right now all the boys are
through college married we have 10
grandchildren and this life insurance
policy the cash value is now around two
hundred and forty thousand dollars
I am just my husband and I are trying to
make this decision he is still working
he has an income of about 80 000 a year
he hopes to retire at about 65. my
income a year after coved I'm a
Christian motivational speaker so my my
uh income dropped from about 50 000 a
year to now 20 000. we are trying to
make the decision of whether we cash in
this whole life policy and put into our
stocks and bonds
portfolio give them the fact of his um
life expectancy to be what's the face
value
240. that's the cash value what's the
difference yes 666
000 right now
okay
um
wow okay
so basically if if he dies or no when he
dies we all die yeah when he dies I
understand you if the policy is in place
you will receive 666. yes sir okay that
means they're going to keep 240. so you
really have a four hundred thousand
dollar insurance policy
correct that's really what you have Okay
um and so the swing is
do you need the extra 400 to live and
the answer is no
you don't
so if you cash it out and put 250 in
there or if you keep it either one
you're going to be okay either way
financially speaking mathematically
speaking agreed
agreed okay so this really comes down to
um
a bet that you're making not based on
the past
but for four hundred thousand dollars
I'm gonna bet that I'm gonna put in less
than four hundred thousand dollars
before he dies
right mathematically it's it's very
cold-hearted but it's a math thing
okay and so it's um you know uh um
and and what's the can she save another
four hundred still it no I'm saying
she's paying for a 400 000 life
insurance policy in essence they are
paying okay okay and um if he dies
before you put 400 into it if you put
300 into it you gained by a hundred
mm-hmm right and that's that's the math
because and is it currently and it will
be forever ten thousand dollars
first since we
we fund that first and then our employee
matching and then our Ross that's been
our yeah well that would not be my order
of priority but if we're just making
bets uh at ten thousand dollars into
four hundred thousand that's 40 years is
it not
yes it is so if you're just placing bets
on the math you're going to keep it
okay it's a crappy product I probably
would have dropped it 15 years ago or 10
years ago uh and save that money and
quit then and I hate it I I think it's a
horrible product but at this stage what
it's come down to is if you're going to
get 666 upon his death which is a weird
number by the way but
um it is it is but the uh if you're
going to get that upon his death then
um and they're going to keep 240 of
yours that's uh 426 difference uh then
he's got to live 42 years
before you don't come out ahead if I'm
doing my math right am I doing something
wrong
I mean 400 divided by 10 is 40 isn't it
yes yeah yes and so for 420 divided by
10 is 42 years he's 62. so he's going to
make it to 104.
um probably not happening I mean I'm
probably not making it to 149 and I got
longevity in my family so you know right
but um and she goes she comes out better
ahead doing that versus testing it all
out taking that 250 and putting it in an
investment yeah I mean that's a very
simplistic way of doing it okay if we
want to get one more level of
sophistication we could say the present
value of that money right in other words
were you to invest ten thousand dollars
a year how long before and at an 11 rate
of return in your stocks and bonds what
the market is returned how long before
you'd get to four hundred thousand I
don't have that off the top of my head
but it's probably still
20 years
right so if if I'm tracking with you
right because this has been a dilemma
for me you know we're pretty financially
Savvy we did Larry Burkett before we
heard of Dave Ramsey and have done the
envelopes before they were cool and I I
think about if I pull out or we I'm
sorry pull out the the cash benefit of
240 000 approximately and I invest that
plus I'm adding I'm freed up ten
thousand dollars a year you're right
your equation is more of complete than
mine
it kind of swings this pendulum the
other way well you got to get the if you
do that you got to get to 666 but you'd
get there in with the 250. seven years
six years
exactly so what you got me you got me
you didn't need me I needed you
okay oh yeah you're exactly right you're
exactly right I left a variable out of
that oh wow that was dumb okay you got
it you're exactly no you're exactly
right
um yeah yeah so what I would do is is
run the couch sit down with your
investment advisor and run the
calculation if you invest it your
current rates of return on your
Investments 250 plus 10 000 and how
quick do you get to 666. that's the
equation and if it's at 11 I think
you're there in about five or six years
is what I think it's going to come out
I'm doing that in my head but I'm not
far off
um so yeah I am going to cash it out
good I feel better because I hate those
dead gum things I know ah I was having
trouble keeping it so you can take his
job I assume pressure motivator
Christian motivational speaker yeah you
can you know we got we have a need for
you you also do math
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Noah is with us
hey know how are you very good sir
honored to be here honored to have you
sir how much debt have you paid off
seventy six thousand dollars and six
hundred dollars
76 and 600 all right how long did this
take you 26 months good for you and your
range of income during that time so
started around 75 000 annually and uh
finished up around 90. good for you what
do you do for a living so I actually
have two jobs uh my uh day job is in
Staffing and recruiting and I teach
violin lessons on the side ah very cool
very cool how much are violin lessons
pay uh I wrote around 60 an hour that's
good right now yeah it's pretty good in
the Northeast yeah yeah very nice where
do you live I live in Somerville
Massachusetts so just North of Boston
yeah very good well welcome to Nashville
congratulations thank you what kind of
debt was the 77 000 all student loans
all of it knocked it out knocked it out
so what put you on this journey to get
out of debt
so it actually started back in 2015 when
I finished school I finished up my um my
Master's Degree and uh music of course
yes okay and at the time I was uh
working trying to figure out my career
but I had a very casual approach to my
finances so during this time I paid off
some smaller debts uh credit cards and a
car loan but very casually not intensely
I think it was uh took me about four
years to pay off fifteen thousand
dollars so when I'd come across your
information Dave and I read about baby
step number two I was like absolutely
overwhelmed thinking that given my
current trajectory it would take me 10
to 15 years to pay off my loans
but um something clicked and the idea of
applying the same intensity to my
finances that I had done with other
areas of my life started to make sense
so work was very steady I had a full
teaching schedule which I was very
grateful for and by early 2020 I had
baby step one in place to just attack my
loans wow amazing thank you so it took a
little over two years yes yes okay so
what was the hardest part of of those
two years for you you know once I
started and just decided to go all in it
it actually became kind of fun I know it
sounds a little crazy
um just seeing the numbers go down yeah
um each month the
um there were some times I actually joke
with some of my friends where I was very
dead set on hitting my uh my monthly
goal where I would I would play a little
risk I would have about 75 dollars my
checking account couple days before
payday just because I was I had to get
that at that that number to hit my loan
so so that was probably that was
probably the I walked on that line a
little bit yeah yeah yeah but it was
worth it I mean like the the sacrifice
and doing all the weird stuff to to be
able to say yeah that you paid off
seventy six thousand seventy seven
thousand dollars in debt yes obviously a
very accomplished violinist
uh I would like to think so yeah I hope
my students think so nobody wants to
listen to you if you don't so nobody
wants to learn from you if you're not so
I take it that's one of the things the
the discipline to become good at that
sometimes people think music uh
musicians uh that's all uh unnatural
gifting and it many times starts with a
natural gifting and it ends with a lot
of hard work
um so I'm guessing there's some of the
discipline you'd applied in that was
what you were talking about yes sir yes
sir yeah same intentionality same level
of discipline if I'm going to be great I
gotta pay a price absolutely absolutely
if I'm gonna be great at Finance I gotta
pay a price very related yeah yeah okay
makes a lot of sense good for you now
what would you so what would you say
Noah to someone who's you know because
the 77 000 that's a very normal amount
of student loan debt right you know we
hear the Crazy Six Figure numbers
sometimes but you're kind of in that
range of like yeah yeah a lot of people
are doing that so if someone's listening
right now and they have 70 80 000
student like yeah but that's just like
it's normal it's whatever one has well
and Biden's gonna pay it off and it
might get paid off right like I don't
know I'm just not that I like I I just
don't think I can do that I don't think
I can really really pay that off what
what would you say to that person that
questions it yeah I would say if someone
were in my shoes like similar
temperament and personality to me is uh
be 100 focused on one thing at a time
because that's I think that intensity
can be a gift at times it can be you
know kind of stubbornness to other
people but uh using that intensity and
drive and be okay with being a little
obsessed with your goals I think I think
just giving my myself permission to to
be a little crazy be a little stubborn
and and just go Um attack attack mode I
guess into it yeah I give you permission
to do that in every area of your life
it's called being successful
um instead of being mediocre this idea
that I'm afraid it might be too intense
uh brother get up off your butt light
yourself on fire and go do something man
this is awesome I'm proud of you thank
you very well done very very well done
good stuff who was your biggest
cheerleaders uh I had a couple
um so so my parents
um my mother has been uh just incredibly
supportive she's the one who uh uh made
me start I say made me start violin
lessons when I was a kid
um but it's definitely paid off and my
father has always been the uh quiet
achiever I like to call him who who's
led by example
um and my girlfriend Amanda as well has
been um I I was kind of I kept it on uh
low-key when I met her that I was you
know kind of on this journey and when I
had showed her my balance of zero she
actually cried so it it actually it hit
me okay she cares too so um it was it
was very appreciated I think I think she
felt your intensity you just didn't know
it I think so
the fact that you wouldn't go out
anywhere other than to the park exactly
exactly
good stuff man very very cool well done
what advice do you have to a young
single person who's accomplished in
every area but money what would you tell
them to do if they want to get out of
debt well I would say if you're already
good at other things the same principles
and discipline apply to finance so I
think the hard part with uh living in
2022 is hearing eight million things of
information at the time that just you
have to do the boring stuff and and uh
the day-to-day is more important than
the
um I guess the flashy you know quick
quick things it's good no very good good
stuff well done sir proud of you we got
a copy of Total Money Makeover for you
in the live and give bundle along with
the baby steps millionaires book and a
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University you might use that to go
through with your girlfriend that'd be
fun I never know what that'll do for
your relationship Excellent Man well
done very proud of you you're a rock
star thank you sir good stuff good stuff
Noah from Boston Mass 77
000 paid off in 26 months making 75 to
90. count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one let's go I'm done
friend yeah
that was definitely a violin move there
definitely
it's awesome that's awesome so great
they're pretty cool and very cool
without a doubt good stuff good stuff
and the live and give bundle is also on
sale if you guys want to share it with
your friends at ramsesolutions.com in
the store and Rachel your new wallet is
in there the new color is out right I
know Christmas gift for women that's
right yes the the red color is here
people have been asking for red so we're
like okay we're gonna do it it's a
limited quality quantity uh but it and
they sell out quick usually when we do
some of these kind of special colors so
make sure to uh you have to pick one up
for you or for the woman in your life
because what's great about this wallet
is the envelopes are built in uh it's
actually real leather it's beautiful we
partner with our friends at join uh to
create this wallet so it is the the
quality of it is is wonderful and it's
great because you can just use this
wallet I mean I kind of even just use it
as a purse sometimes just to run in and
out of the store to run errands and it's
and it's amazing so all other colors
have done great but people keep asking
for red so we heard you America and have
a limited quantity for that color so you
can go to Rachel or you can go to
ramsesolutions.com today to get the
Rachel Cruz wallet in red yeah check it
out joins a fair trade company and this
is a full grain leather we partnered
with them because they're giving people
a work that desperately need work to uh
to make a transition in their life off
the street usually in ndis in India and
uh so every time you buy one of these
you're helping someone literally and
we're we're helping them as well by
doing this deal with them and these
bullets have been vastly popular every
time we come out of the color it sells
really really fast oh I know so here we
go the red ones at ramseysolutions.com
just in time for Christmas this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage ambers
with us hi Amber how are you hi great to
be here thank you guys good to have you
where do you live Indianapolis Indiana
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off 37
193.59 phenomenal how long did this take
uh 22 months good for you and your range
of income during that two years uh so
started out uh net 52 and ended at 67.
cool what do you do for a living I got
promoted and I'm currently a financial
analyst manager now well congratulations
very cool but these numbers you were
killing it yeah that's I mean you were
living on nothing nothing nothing
what uh what was the 37 000. uh all
student loan oh got rid of old Sallie
Mae yep kicked her out of the house love
it yep she'd been a pet unfortunately uh
I started uh about 12 years ago is
really I had car to instant loan debt
and uh
I I was Davis for a while I um went out
to eat and sorry my headphone sorry
um and uh just didn't I didn't have the
hope it just felt like a mountain of
debt sorry I'm like you're doing good
it's all good okay I'm sorry what is uh
what got you started then 22 months ago
what jacked you up
um so I finally just it kicked it in
gear when I got accountability for my
daughter I'm sorry I am like yeah it's
falling off the back of her head just
move it up yeah there you go all right
good job good job okay sorry perfect
they're great okay so and um my biggest
thing was making my daughter like being
accountable to my daughter and I what
finally because I had a thermometer I
kept staring at for like months that
like I really wouldn't get started but I
finally made up that change because I'd
seen a bunch of debt free screens and
they did the chains and I was like you
know what let me get her involved and as
soon as like I we made the chains
together the links to together and I was
looking in those big blue eyes I
couldn't let her down so she's pretty
tiny for all that big accountability how
old is she she's four four okay so a
four-year-old whip you into shape
yep I I didn't want her to ever know
what college loans felt like the weight
of those student loans ever so I just
got really really old didn't it yeah I
got tired oh amazing we did incredible
so what did you do to get out of debt
what was your process then uh so
trying to think here what was my process
just I mean just the normal things
getting at like uh getting a budget
staying on a budget prioritizing because
there's so many that's why I want to
talk to single moms about there's a
million distractions flexing your no
muscle and then making that budget and
knowing that there's hope like you
really do have hope like it might be a
mountain of debt it really can be but
there's still hope and you don't I my
personal story is I want to spend time
with Meadow and so I didn't do a lot of
side hustles but I worked really hard on
my career and I really tapped into Ken
Coleman with making my purpose and
really working on my career and just
showing excellence in my workplace
um so that I could add value and I
actually called in um to the show asking
if I should ask for a raise yeah
um and you kind of kicked me in the butt
which is great
and so I was actually yes of course yeah
yeah and you were like well how are you
adding value because like yes you're
getting responsibility but how are you
really adding value put yourself in the
position of your boss and that really
clicked for me I was like okay what's my
what's my growth plan forward how can I
add value and my boss is an amazing
leader and um I didn't use exactly all
that but I really kind of took some of
those principles and added like okay how
can how can I grow in this and how can I
add value to where I'm currently at
which I've been there for eight years so
yeah so how'd you get plugged into doing
the Ramsey Way of money
um I think I had a friend back in
college in grad school that was into it
and I just kind of got connected started
listening on YouTube that was what
really like clicked for me when I
started hearing the debt free screams
John and Maddie hearing their stories
yeah John and Maddie's story yeah oh wow
okay yeah yeah so back then it was been
a little bit ago but yeah that I finally
got like really serious uh 22 months ago
and if I heard the rumor right you ended
up in their financial peace class uh
close to yes there I'm in Indiana and uh
so we've been friends like over like
virtually oh okay just a virtual
connection but it wasn't a clash yeah
yeah okay all right cool yeah yeah well
they've been super coordinators
obviously all over the of course have
led people Mentor people all over the
world so I didn't know exactly how it
happened good very good good for you
guys so Amber for me being the single
mom that you are that's a hard that's a
hard journey in general
um and then on top of that doing a
sacrificial work with your money to get
out of debt so talk to all the single
moms out there because I know it's there
you guys have so much responsibility and
I know you're already exhausted I can't
even imagine and so
um what encouragement do you have for
single moms out there that that you did
this you got you got yourself out of
debt I mean it's so impressive yeah I
just thank you Rachel um it is it's hard
but um I wanted to talk to those single
moms because I came out of a abusive
marriage
and it was really hard but I had to work
on myself
um and when I did that
um one thing is I I lost about 70 to 80
pounds wow we're exercised and then
getting financially fit too wow and um
the biggest thing for me was Hope just
hope that you can you can you believe in
yourself you work your butt off but you
believe in yourself that you really in
God obviously he's gonna produce and
give you favor but really believe that
you can make that income to make it
happen that you can make those
sacrifices and those sacrifices are so
worth it this is so worth it so yeah
yeah you are amazing
I mean 70 80 pounds and 37 000 in 22
months making 52 to 67. that's living on
nothing I mean when you set your mind to
Something There Ain't No Stopping You
girl this is pretty impressive yeah very
impressive I'm proud of you yeah very
very good stuff yep I've really just all
the vision casting that you and Rachel
and Ken and everybody on the personality
team has really in in John deloney have
really helped me give that that juice
that I needed to keep making those
decisions I'd hear you guys in my head
saying you know just pushing me on
um I remember a pivotal moment I was
driving back I was commuting in my car
an hour away and I it was one of your
leadership and you were talking about be
the Thoroughbred among the donkeys and
just having that Spirit of excellence
and that's actually what promoted me
like going from like 27 000 to like 50
at the time and just hearing that it
just really set a fire so every time I
just use the YouTube and books to really
fire me up and and really just make
progress wow
she's incredible Amber for years you're
killing it you're killing it though good
stuff hey we've got the live and give
bundle for you The Total Money Makeover
book The Baby Steps From millionaires
book in a one-year membership to
Financial Peace University to use or to
give away so let's bring Meadow up and
introduce her to the world how she's
four years old you said right yes are
you four years old yeah and has she been
practicing her dead free screen have you
been practicing
ready to go all right good stuff she's
beautiful thank you well done very well
done all right it's Amber and Meadow
from Indianapolis 37
000 paid off in 22 months making 52 to
67. count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one what
foreign
[Music]
the amount of emotional and spiritual
transformation to come out of an abusive
situation to go through that much
transformation
amazing absolutely so empowering she can
I mean the confidence the confidence
that she has whoa love it it's amazing
yeah
this is the Ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
screams everywhere this hour
[Music]
lots of good stuff happening out there
in America in spite of all the news who
knew Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is
my co-host today
if you like this show please help us by
considering subscribing if you will
listen as a podcast or watch on YouTube
hit the Subscribe button always leave a
review especially if you're going to
leave a good one
a five star would be preferable and uh
of course share this with a friend this
show has been on the air for 30 years we
started as a talk radio show we still
are
642 radio stations as of today and the
second largest Talk Radio Show in
America but also in the top one percent
of podcasts in the world over we're one
of five shows has had over a billion
downloads and
um we're in the top one percent of
people in terms of this month of
listening uh listenership or not
listenership hours listened to this is
the way they're measuring it now so it
used to be we measured on downloads we
change it all the time around here and
around in the in the world of digital so
um and uh YouTube very successful as
well so thank you and that's all because
you guys share it that's where it came
from when you said hey god listen to Sky
on the radio hey you got to listen to
this Rachel on the podcast hey you gotta
you gotta do that that's how this stuff
works and we help we appreciate you
sharing it um and you literally can
share it with it and digitally by
clicking the share button with somebody
or you can just tell somebody at work
hey oh you tell your friend oh you got
to listen to this and that's what we're
hearing it did shock me when we got
results of how people find the show
still the highest number is still word
of mouth oh yeah
um which gives me hope of relationships
in our world today we're like oh people
do so they're still to connect talk to
people yes I know you sure do Ann is
with us and is in Nashville hi Anne how
are you
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
um so student loans are starting back up
pretty soon the interest rates on those
um my husband and I have about 30 000
and our only other debt is the house
um we have four different accounts one
unsubscribed and three subsidized and I
know that student loans are simple
interest so I guess the interest accrued
can't continue to accrue interest
so should we be paying a income driven
repayment so that that gets our payments
over so we can attack the principal and
then Circle back it doesn't change it at
all
no nope doesn't change at all all that
changes it is the amount you pay in
okay because the interest is charged on
your outstanding balance regardless of
how the outstanding balance was achieved
even if we pay the the principal down if
you pay the principal down you've if you
pay down anything on the account that is
all it all becomes principal if you
don't pay it
so when you're doing income basing
you're not even covering the interest
you're increasing the principle
you're taking out a one-pocket and
putting it in the other it's still it's
a dollar swap so no you're better off
what's your household income
uh I think I take home 50 and my husband
takes on 30. 30. okay so 80 000 how fast
you're gonna pay off 30k
uh we're thinking two years I'm thinking
one
I'm thinking you need to quit going out
to eat and going on vacations because
the salad this Sallie Mae has been in
your life way too freaking long lady
yeah it's time to punch it in the face
thirty thousand out of eighty thousand
it's not realistic in your mind but it
is in my mind because I've watched
hundreds and hundreds thousands of
people do it over the last 30 years
but you're just still trying to figure
this out with math and I want you to get
pissed off at this situation and sick
and tired of being sick and tired and
sacrificed so deeply that your friends
think you've joined a cult
that's when you'll get out of debt
yeah the greater you're in you're not
going to fix this with math you're still
trying to fix it with your brain your
brain got you into this mess
your brain told you it was okay to
borrow to go to school
you there yeah you there yeah yeah
okay hey I uh I I I can hear the words
you're using and the way you're forming
your sentences
um and uh the reason I can hear it is I
am a fellow nerd
yeah okay so I'm the nerd I can tell
offender I'm also the spender though I
know me too me too I'm gonna that we're
an unusual lot we spend our nerds are
unusual but uh but I can hear the nerd
you're still cranking the math
you're trying to figure out the way the
interest is calculated and use that as
somehow a shortcut to get out of debt
and what you need is 30 freaking
thousand dollars now
right that solves all your math problems
boom just like that oh yeah just
throwing a grenade yes throwing a
grenade in the middle of the swamp the
snakes go everywhere
and it's there's this intensity and
logic leaves and it's sacrifice and it's
this I'm I I like my freaking life
depends on it like my hair is on fire
and you the people that get out of debt
the fastest and actually the easiest are
the ones that do that
right activating this emotion
and that's what we're known for yep
well and that's and that's the progress
and because here's the deal I'm like you
can sacrifice to a level for two years
or you can sacrifice deeply for one year
you just cut it in half the sacrifice is
more intense but it's in a shorter
amount of time and then once it's done
you have enough clothes in your closet
to make it a year you don't need to buy
anything else yep you work extra all you
do is work you cut off all your stupid
cable everything else you don't need to
be watching type of connections you need
to be you need to be dadgum getting your
work done the crown the crown I haven't
heard Tiger King in probably two years
uh Yellowstone there you go guilty
pleasure Dave way to be relevant there
we go all right and um well yeah and so
um
I do want to see about that and on The
View
I'm sorry what Beth Dutton on The View
on The View the show The View wouldn't
that be great if you could get the
character Beth Dutton to go on The View
oh oh oh oh I don't watch Yellowstone I
don't know what you're talking about oh
you don't know no I don't know what
you're talking about all the Yellowstone
fans can you talk a lot of his blinds
again this That season we can talk that
but okay uh but no but the point is like
when you're look when you're looking at
the math of her situation her and her
husbands
and you're used to living on 80. going
down to 50. it's very hard it's hard but
you do it for a year
and to your point it's that it's that
emotion there there's something
happening and the point is not the point
of the conversation is not is 12 months
magic it could be 14. it could be 11.
it's not the Magic Moment the point is
to increase the intensity
because that is the secret sauce this
gazelle intensity that's what we named
this debit card after the gazelle card
it's gazelle intensity from Proverbs
like the gazelle running from the
cheetah uh you're running for your life
and when you get that that's when your
life is transformed people there's
something that the great motivator let's
uh Les Brown used to say the and does
say still the your life changes when you
say I've
had it not when I figured out the math
and I tried I'm a math nerd so I can
hear math nerd a mile away I know I know
nerd speak I can hear it and uh I'm the
same way always trying to figure out a
way sharing my wife uh and my wife would
always say quit scheming and scamming
your scheme is going to be trying to
figure out easy way just do the work
just roll up your sleeves and do the
work stop trying to stop it stop it just
yeah just get after it and there's this
get it thing there's a thing there
that's going on and um and then and you
know then you pick up uh didn't she say
she's a nurse no I don't know I think
she'd pick up extra all kinds of extra
hours you know because there's all kinds
of if you're in the medical field good
Lord you can work all you want and uh
because there's a shortage of everything
if you're in the teaching field there's
a shortage of everything if you're in
the First Responders world you're
there's a shortage of everything you can
work all you want and uh and then some
you work more than you can physically do
and and just go crazy for a short period
of time then you got the whole rest of
your life to be free
but the stinking student loan will hang
around like a disease man
you can't yeah if it won't you can
wander in but you cannot wander out you
gotta bust your way out fighting clawing
machetes axes Bazookas I mean you got a
good you got violence inflict of
violence on the situation emotionally
and that's that is the secret folks
that's the big deal
everybody's thinking I'm going to
refinance my credit card debt from 18 to
14 and that will get no won't help you
same stupid thinking that got you in the
first place
good call in we think you can do it
we're proud of you we can't wait to hear
from you whether it's 12 14 or even 24
months we'll cheer you on either way
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books our thanks to Austin Ben
Zach Andrew and James in the booth the
booth dudes that do the show Rachel Cruz
good hour this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
we'd love for you to come to Nashville
and tell Dave your story that's
ramsaysolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where that
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage might be a sign to hear a
baby steps millionaire we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships in
case you didn't catch the clue this is a
baby steps millionaire theme hour Rachel
Cruz Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host this
hour we will be talking to people who
are actual millionaires regardless of
how you got there whether you're an
everyday millionaire meaning you got
there starting from nothing but didn't
necessarily use the baby steps whether
you followed our baby steps and became a
baby steps millionaire or whether you
just hit the lottery or maybe you're the
next Taylor Swift I don't know you've
got a million dollars though and I don't
wanna I wanna know how you got it
because we've got a few more of them she
might have a couple more than one she
might me up she might be out more than
one while we were talking but um anyway
million dollars millionaire what is a
millionaire it's not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
a millionaire the definition of a
millionaire is your net worth is greater
than a million dollars your net worth is
what you own
minus what you owe
your assets minus your liabilities that
is your net worth period if you're a
cash millionaire that would mean you had
at least a million dollars in cash if
you're a real estate millionaire you're
at least a million dollars in real
estate but a millionaire is simply what
you own minus what you owe equals a
million dollars that's all it is nothing
else is it enough that's not the
discussion is it too much that's not the
discussion are you a bad Christian
that's not the discussion we can talk
about any of those things if you want to
but we want to talk to real Millionaires
and find out how they got there if you
are a real millionaire we'll take your
call right now because I want to
interview you the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rachel is in Orange County but I
didn't pick her up I picked up the wrong
line because I'm stupid all right Rachel
in Orange County hey Rachel how much is
your net worth
hi Dave hi Rachel it's an honor to speak
to you today
we currently sit at 3.3 million and we
are baby step millionaires way to go all
right give me a little breakdown on the
3.3 how should allocate what categories
yes sir so we have uh 1.7 in our paid
off house we have approximately 1.1 in
our retirement account uh 100 000 in
liquid cash and about 400 000 in limited
partnership Investments good all right
very cool how old are you guys
I'm 40 and my husband is 48. okay cool
and how much of the 3.3 million did you
inherit
thousand upon his passing and which was
incredibly generous uh for him to do
yeah but uh we had already uh passed our
million dollar net worth before that
happened oh so you were already
millionaires we were sir okay wow so
just added to it amazing okay so what's
been your household income best year and
worst year since you started adulthood
so uh well really probably adulthood I
mean when we entered uh enter into our
field uh we were probably a range of
income net of about 150 to 300 000. okay
and the high was 300. yes sir okay all
right what are your careers
well my husband and I are both in law
enforcement okay wow all right very good
all right in what form do you mind
saying or can you
um yes sir so uh I am a I'm a supervisor
in law enforcement and my uh my husband
is an executive leadership in a law in
our department okay very good good for
you okay are your degrees in criminal
justice
my degree started off in Psychology but
I could not do the whole fit in an
office uh thing so my office was my
patrol car and uh and then I eventually
got my masters in criminal justice as
well as human services my husband's
degree he decided to go to Junior
College for a very long time and then
got into law enforcement and then
through the department got his criminal
justice degree his bachelor's and then
ultimately a master of science in
emergency Administration wow okay that's
impressive yeah so what were you what
was your gpas through some of that just
want to pick out one well sir I I
definitely got a lot more motivated when
I became an adult had skin in the game
and so I graduated with my masters with
a 4.0 but we're just average ordinary
you know 3.0 you know in high school and
college so but we we've really kind of
turned turned up the heat when we became
adults okay so um
what do you tell people that you know
you're 40 48 years old there's a 24 year
old looking to go into law enforcement
they say yeah but there's no money in
that
um I'll never I'll never be a
millionaire
um what do you tell them how do you tell
them do you tell them to do this it's
yes and this is something that we're
actually very fortunate
um we we live this we tell this to our
young young deputies that start off I
mean this is something very that changed
our life Dave and we're grateful for you
and we're grateful for this program we
just actually finished up uh
facilitating in our church in spu we
just got done with our nine weeks
um our our people just graduated this
past Tuesday so it's something that
we're going to continue to to give back
and do that but yeah you absolutely can
do it but you have to get on a budget
you have to live below your means and
then also your choice in spouse is one
of the most important decisions in your
life and I have been so blessed Beyond
Comprehension with my husband he's the
best partner in life and love that I
could have ever prayed for and asked for
he's absolutely selfless and selfless
and inspires me every day to be a better
person to be a better partner just to be
a better contributor and we might not
always see eye to eye on everything but
we both always try to at least learn
mean open to each other's ideas because
I'll tell you in in true honesty I went
Kicking and Screaming to FPU in 2014 and
it was because of uh it was because of a
friend that we worked with she was
diagnosed with rare cancer and when we
were looking at how we could financially
contribute to help them through this
difficult time we could not give what we
wanted to give without it crippling us
financially and I knew that I needed to
change and I knew that we needed to do
something different with the tremendous
blessings of this career and our
finances and I was not being a good
Steward of those finances and it was
truly like God had placed Us in that
class at that time in 2014 and that
first class I was an absolute convert I
was a free spirit that has transformed
into a nerd at times and I I can't
believe the amazing things that this is
set forth for us it has changed our
family tree and we just we are so
grateful wow we're grateful for you wow
what a great story I love it and so
inherited nothing until after you were
millionaires 3.3 million dollar net
worth by 40 and 48 years old you guys
are amazing impressive so proud of you
thank you very much and the secret sauce
too is uh once once we really committed
to tithing and giving God his first and
best
magic things happen God you cannot out
give God and we are just we're Living
testament to that amen and amen and
thank you for leading Financial Peace
University classes and for helping out
those deputies yes very good stuff
congratulations Rachel thanks for
calling in baby steps millionaires theme
hour this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we talked to
real millionaires to find out how they
really did it not your broke
brother-in-law's opinion but how you
really build wealth or is it really come
from in America today which gives you
the best chance and by the way we've
never interviewed with someone that said
they did it with Bitcoin
we've never interviewed someone that
said they did it with airline miles from
their credit cards
we've never interviewed someone who said
they got rich with whole life life
insurance we have never interviewed
someone that said I became a millionaire
because I leased cars just giving you
some insight
some things to think about and then
we've been doing this a long time Sherry
is with us next in Destin Florida Sherry
what's your net worth
hey Dave it is 3.4 million dollars love
it give me a little breakdown on that by
category
okay well I have a little over 2 million
in real estate I have uh some CDs and uh
mutual funds how much are the CDs
uh well I'm just getting started back
into that since the interest rates are
going up so about around a hundred
thousand okay and how much in mutual
funds
uh around 250 000. okay what's the rest
of it
[Applause]
um the image right now I've sold a few
houses in the last few years that I've
been holding on to the cash that's in
the bank and I'm getting ready to
reinvest it but I've been kind of
watching from the sidelines to see what
would be the best Avenues there's
something like a million cash
uh I hate to say a bit uh close to it
yeah okay I was actually thinking about
I have uh nine houses and I was
contemplating I'm buying another one but
I was also waiting on that okay how old
are you
I am 62. cool all right and how much of
this 3.4 million did you inherit
none zero okay and what's your best year
working lifetime in your worst year
working lifetime your income
I'm going to have to say probably last
year was my
well not this last present year not 2022
but 2021 was my best
and probably in my worst was uh the
first year after I was divorced 29 years
what'd you make around five thousand
dollars okay what'd you make last year
121. oh 21 I made uh like 76 000. okay
wow what's your career
I am a musician a photographer and uh
owner of the rental houses okay do you
have a degree four-year degree I
I have a two-year degree in recreational
leadership okay what was your GPA
yeah 3.5 okay if you're talking to
someone 22 32 years old out there 30 40
years behind you can they still do this
and what should they do if they want to
be you when they grow up
um well I say uh find something that you
love to do and find a way to make money
at it that's basically what I did
um even if the photography didn't come
and play until my 40s but that was like
my second love to music which I didn't
start that as a career until I was in my
early 30s
um along with the rental houses but I
would say find something you love to do
find a way to make money at it also pay
cash for cars and most things that you
can and save save save
you've been a savings machine
only had made I think I made 75
000 one year
um 2000 maybe eight it was the rest of
the time it was between 30 and 50.
pretty impressive that is impressive
yeah thank you because for a lot of
people they think you know that your
income
um has everything to do with it right in
a sense that you know that their habits
oh yeah you know aren't as big of a deal
but you're the you're the living proof
your story is no what you do with that
income is what changes the game
exactly I had a lot of friends who made
a lot more money than me yeah but they
didn't have what I had I just always cut
my mouth shut and just kept going on
with my plan and
you're amazing well done Sherry very
well done excellent excellent job I love
it Michael and Jody are with us in
Fresno hey guys what's your net worth
hi Dave and Rachel nice to meet you hi
David Rachel nice to meet you you too
um our net worth
worth point two
five okay give me a little breakdown on
that by category
uh we have 500 in a 401k we have about
55 000 in a Roth IRA
uh 225 and a pension
about 365 in our house we still owe
about 55 000 on our house so once that's
paid off or you know about 365. about 40
cash and about 30 in our cars way to go
how old are you guys
I am 58 Dave and I'm 55. okay awesome
very good and how much of this 1.25 did
you inherit
zero zero all right what's the best year
income of your working life and your
worst year income of your working life
household income
I would say a hundred thousand as our
best and probably 40 worst okay and what
are your careers
Dave I uh drive a truck for a Food
Service Company
and I work in admin in a doctor's office
cool are you have four-year degrees or
two-year degrees
zero
degrees uh I didn't graduate from high
school Dave okay wow what was your high
school GPA uh Jody
I would say probably about 3.5 and
Michael dropped out his senior year and
then he went back and got his GED oh God
okay cool cool so why why are you
millionaires what did you do what do you
tell people if they want to follow in
your footsteps
Rockies I got a song but you get to talk
yeah
she was a huge part of it she's actually
took your FPU class and yes um by
herself I might say and uh brought it
home to me and said hey I want to do
this so you want to be on board and I
said sure let's let's do it so we went
ahead and did that so she's because of
you in in your class she really kicked
this off so and and she she's just a
really good budget budget
budget knows how to handle
well we've always had a budget but not
until we took your class about 15 plus
years ago and the envelope system oh my
gosh I fell in love with your envelope
system and
I just thank you for sharing your wisdom
over the years that I think God has
given that to you I love how
you
um you know we always agree and we say
that everything that we have comes from
the Lord but I never really how you use
the analogy of he just wants us to
manage it he wants us to be good
managers and so that's how we feel about
it and so we
um the envelope system has just
transformed our finances and I share it
with everybody Mike and light we've even
gone on Facebook live and done a couple
of budgeting videos just because we like
I could talk about budgeting all day
and we always give credit to you for the
envelope system
um and we share that just to encourage
people that it's not too late you can
you know save up for things we were able
to cash fund our youngest daughter's
wedding
um we were able to
um pay cash for a car that we bought it
was three years old at the time but we
would have never been able to do that
and so we're just so grateful and we
just love to share with other people and
encourage them that it can be done well
you did today philosophy is if you work
if you actually work you make money and
you can be able to save some of it
that's a genius that's just genius I
love it I completely agree I completely
agree quit trying to figure out a way to
not work oh well done you guys you guys
are amazing beautifully done fabulous
man I love it thanks for sharing that is
great uh so we got master's degrees
two-year junior college and high school
graduate and GED yeah so far we're going
for the most Spectrum the full spectrum
so far of millionaires calling in I
think we don't see a correlation there
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
CNN reporting America gained two and a
half new millionaires last year the
number of rich people in the world Rose
at a rapid Pace last year boosted by
gains in the stock market and house
prices
as many as 5.2 million people became
millionaires worldwide with the United
States being two and a half million the
largest increase in millionaire numbers
recorded for any country in any year in
this century
pretty interesting worldwide the number
of millionaire stands at about 62 and a
half million last numbers I had showed
the U.S at about 15 million I don't see
it mentioned in this article what they
are how many of them there are in this
um you know this thing well a million
dollars is not enough well it's
interesting that they said gains from
the stock market because I feel like
Mark is down though now I know so I
guess it was just last year after 2020
last year it was up so yeah but you've
got then you've got 20 23 to or 2022 to
help you with that problem came back
down yeah uh we're talking to real
millionaires this year wanting to know
how you really did it our research
deemed as the largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
we studied over 10 000 of them and we
found the top five careers of
millionaires uh very interesting
engineer was number one accountant was
number two
teacher was number three Management
number four number five was attorney
MDS medical doctors didn't make the top
five they're number six teachers are
number three
and um what we couldn't figure out was
that teacher one kind of doesn't fit in
there with the rest of these you kind of
go yeah I get it I mean management
accountant engineer I get that they a
make money be either you know very
numbers oriented but teachers attorneys
attorneys make money some of them a lot
of them got a lot of debt and so the net
worth of that still being there
um but but one thing we finally kept
looking at this and going okay this is
not a mistake all of these
career paths are process people
they're not flashing the Pan People
attorneys you use a process to work your
way through the law it's logical it's
critical thinking you do this then you
do this then you do this if you don't
the judge doesn't let you move you know
that kind of thing
you know business is a series of
processes and systems accounting
engineering teachers lesson planning you
know running a classroom it's a process
for a greater result over a long period
of time none of these are get rich quick
kind of flash in the pan random
kind of movement chaotic people right
they live day in and day out in their
careers in this method yeah they're very
method yes way of living so naturally
that's going to leak into other areas of
your life you're naturally that's how
you're bent and that's how you're
spending 40 hours 40 plus hours a week
and that same mindset that's fascinating
exactly and the other thing that we
revealed like our last caller there uh
last two callers actually uh one third
of the millionaires in our study we
found 33 percent of them had never made
a household income of over a hundred
thousand dollars and two of our three so
far have not
uh very interesting so we reveal all of
this in this put the study white paper
in the back of the book uh all of the
processes that we have studied for 30
years to show people how they became
millionaires in the number one
bestseller baby steps millionaires we
launched it last January it is a huge
Blockbuster bestseller thank you guys we
appreciate you uh how you can use the
seven baby steps as the fastest right
way to become wealthy and uh to be
unbelievably unreasonably generous and
uh this is the first time ever right now
it's on sale for ten dollars at our
website at
ramseysolutions.com nice job for the
holidays ten dollars for baby steps
millionaires John is in Statesboro
Georgia John what is your net worth
it's about a million dollars right now
okay your phone just cut out try again
how much
hey Dave I'm sorry we're around seven
million dollars right now wow very good
give me a little breakdown on that by
category
[Music]
two or three million in cash actually
and we own a substantial amount of real
estate probably 10 million dollars worth
of Real Estate
and we don't have any in the stock
market really we have a little bit in
retirement my wife just retired she's 36
she was a nurse for 10 years and
um I think you may see we have an
interesting story we've never made over
a hundred grand for the past 10 years
and we just tackled it we we opened the
business and tackled it on it and I
think last year we made 1.3 million was
what we pay taxes on what is your
business
well I graduated college and I was
working at a grocery store as a stalker
and my wife was a nurse and she went to
school we paid for college ourselves had
jobs and I ended up opening a small
grocery store and I sold it and now we
have 10 grocery stores that we owned
and um that we own the property too in
the business so that's what we're into
the grocery business ah so the net worth
on the grocery business was one point
throw the net income was 1.3 the gross
that had to be the net well
um that was just my net
that I pay taxes on yeah yeah that's
what the income I drew out of it that's
what you really took home yeah so what
is so your career is the grocery
business did you get a degree
well I did I got a business degree but
we're not big fans of college you know I
think it's overpriced and we're we have
four children
and um I think there's a lot of other
opportunities out there yeah yes I did
get a degree in four years instead of my
life when you pay for it you tend to do
it on time I hear you okay and you're a
GPA
um I had a decent GPA probably like a
3.2 now my wife had a 40 through college
okay she's a little smarter
always the case always the case so you
would attribute your wealth which you've
done unbelievable how old are you
uh 36 what about 36. wow great job and
you inherited zero it sounds like from
the story
we heard a little bit from some people
but other than that we were happy to
help how about that
okay so um
you know you your your story is an
entrepreneur story
you built you built a business is where
your money came from
it is but you know during the
during the we never lived in our means
we I I never bought a 20 ounce soda
until I had a million dollar net worth
and we you know we never missed the time
we we always did what's right and um we
just we just kept grinding and grinding
and my wife worked hard for those years
while I kind of pursued some of our
dreams
you're plowing everything back into the
business and she's she's paying the
light bill with her nursing job that's
correct but you know when you got so
most of this business is paid for
um there's some dental some of the real
estate portion but when you've got a lot
of that kind of a lot of that cash flow
it really just kind of comes on you all
at once you know once you get out of
debt
yeah I think it did you guys are
incredible okay so uh what are you
telling the Next Generation you're 36
what's the 26 or 24 year old dude that's
watching us on YouTube right now oh I
was 26 years old and my wife and I both
took a Financial Peace University class
we were in four hundred thousand dollars
in debt at the time non-business related
oh wow and we we work and work and
worked I mean it was a lot of it was our
house some of it with some rental
properties that we had bet on and we did
anything we could do my wife went and
worked at another hospital I went and
worked at another store I started the
business after business and we just
anytime we made a dollar we just we
basically invested in ourselves so my my
advice would be to invest in yourself
and do it wisely no you put in a lot of
long hard hours in the last decade
yes sir yeah
but now you're 36 and can do anything
you want to do right well we paid cash
for 300 acres and me and my son are
hunting this afternoon after school
that's awesome so the law has definitely
been good to us Dave yeah I think he has
and uh I think you planted plenty of
corn and he brought the rain in the sun
you did not plant sparingly you re
you're reaping a bonus because you
planted a bonus well done sir very very
proud of you good stuff good job John
good to talk to you man you're an
incredible young guy very cool seven
million dollars in the grocery business
doing it in a decade it's amazing wow
wow wow yep there you go nothing fancy
let's get it
didn't he I don't think he was quiet
quitting was he
quite the opposite of quiet wedding a
lot of hard work a lot of hard work John
and his wife went through well done John
this is a baby steps millionaire theme
hour
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today John 14 6 Jesus
answered I am the way and the truth and
the life no one comes to the father
except through me
Craig Rochelle said be careful not to
blame yourself if someone rejects Christ
if you do you might be tempted to take
credit when someone accepts him
it's our friend Craig you were just you
were just with Pastor Craig and Amy the
other day weren't you I was last week
yeah was it last week week four lasted
and now Tom gets away I'm losing my my
focus we were in November I don't know
where I was I don't know where I am I
don't even know where I am right now
let's be honest
All Over America in the last 45 days
speaking to you folks and we're honored
to do it it's a baby steps millionaire
theme hour so chin is with us in Seattle
hey suchin what's your net worth
hello uh it's an honor to speak with you
guys so right now our net worth is
around 1.65 billion dollars excellent
give me a little breakdown on that by
category uh it's uh spread across real
estate and uh 401k and uh in other
Investments uh in visual fund how much
is in real estate
um so I I think uh around one point uh
the gross 1.5 1.6 I think okay and how
much in uh your 401k
uh 401K is uh around 300. okay cool and
then how much in the mutual funds that
are not retirement
[Music]
trunk excellent well done uh how old are
you
uh I'm 34. my life is 32. good cool and
how much of this did you inherit
uh nothing zero okay and how much what's
your best year of income since you've
been working in your worst year of
income since you've been working
household income
so uh our income has been growing every
year
um and so the best year was the last
year and of course the worst year was uh
when I was a student chair how much did
you make and what was your income when
you were a student
uh nothing I had to borrow money to pay
for my gotcha okay and what's your been
your best year working income-wise what
was your interest
so last year I think we made around 350
000 wow what do you do for a living
so I'm in a tech company here in the
Pacific Northwest and what do you do for
the tech company
I'm a software engineer ah okay very
good you know a four-year degree in that
and information systems or what
uh so I did my uh bachelor's degree in
uh in India and I moved here for my
Master's Degree
um yeah so that's where that's how uh
my education was and yeah gotcha so your
Master's is in information systems or
what yes okay that's right okay cool and
uh your GPA
uh I want to say it's around 3.6 okay
cool all right and uh so
talk to uh the person out there who's
come here from another country like you
did uh is this possible still and what
is the secret to becoming a millionaire
very much possible and you just have to
um you know uh
uh be uh go to college finish a degree
and land a job and start investing from
your very first paycheck um that's I
believe that's the secret
sounds logical to me brother hey thank
you for calling and sharing your story
we really appreciate it let's see if we
can sneak in one more David is in
Charlotte North Carolina David what is
your net worth
two million two million give me a little
breakdown by category
well my primary residence which I paid
off is worth about three quarters of a
million
I've got uh commercial real estate about
465. it's got a couple of retirement
accounts I haven't tapped yet but
they're worth about a half a million
um and then I have uh cash accounts you
know cash Brokers non-retirement
accounts with another 100
uh 100 000 about 50 000 in cash uh about
a hundred thousand and Things That Go
room with motors
um one of which surprisingly is
appreciating but I didn't buy it for an
investment I bought it because it's fun
with my kids about forty thousand and
five twenty nine plans fifteen thousand
uh health savings account I bought one I
bond this year for ten thousand okay so
uh how old are you
53. how much of this did you inherit
70 000 uh when my dad passed and uh I
gotta say it it made such a difference
at that time it's not a big percentage
of my net worth now but it insulated me
from so many risks but the real
uh the real gift I got from him was what
he told me growing up was about 85
percent consistent with uh what you tell
people wow okay about money now what do
you do for a living
I'm retired I'm a uh from Paid work I'm
a widower stay-at-home dad now so I make
dinner and I shop and I sweep up dog
here what was your what was your career
I I was an I.T uh manager for local
County government okay and you did well
enough that uh with this uh taking care
of kiddos and the situation you find
yourself in that you don't have to work
anymore that's excellent I love that
okay I opened a uh Ira when I was a
senior in college
okay so what is the secret to getting to
a two million dollar net worth by 53
years old in your mind
well I you know you know it's I'm sorry
you don't have more time I'll just give
you the bullets man because it's I saved
early and often I I did something for
money since age 11. like I saved up 8
000 from paper routes and working for
three dollars and fifteen cents an hour
in the 80s so regularly putting by from
your paycheck and then investing and
leaving it alone which is super hard for
me to do I had to open a second account
which is like a tiny like three percent
of my net worth I can allow I allow
myself to lose money by trading too much
in that account basically
um but well I learned the more I touched
it and the more I looked the worse I did
so yeah Buy and Hold really works better
than messing around with it amen uh and
and then not overspending on a house
avoiding the two income trap my late
wife and I bought a fixer-upper we fixed
it up we lived in it for eight years but
then we uh we managed to qualify for a
mortgage on a completely different house
without having to sell that house and so
we rented it and I solder couple and so
I got the appreciation of two houses uh
well we were renting as a mediocre
landlord it's not for me I managed to
both not make any money and take off the
tenants but they they paid me they paid
down the mortgage so like when was when
I sold it like they I paid it off with
their help but they they I put 42 000
the six years I rented it towards the
mortgage from their rent I love it very
well done David proud of you man
congratulations very well done okay
millionaires we talked to today 3.3
million four point three point four one
two five seven million one six five and
two million uh the only person that
inherited anything prior to having a
million dollars was this last one he
inherited seventy thousand yeah uh one
couple inherited 350 after they were
already millionaires law enforcement uh
truck driver grocery store owner
software engineer I.T manager retired
and a musician all over the map uh
what's the proof here anybody can do it
Rachel
which I love the um all the questions
that you ask but you get the you get the
range of Ages the range of income the
range of of jobs and careers but it's
that consistent live on less than you
make put money away and work hard yep 34
32 36 age 58 55 62 48 40 and 53 so uh no
one under 30 no one
over 60 but one over 65. over 60 no one
over 65. that'd be why I'm saying it
yeah so
um this is consistent too with the
findings of the study that we published
in baby steps millionaires so um to
think how the rest of America
the stats that we're seeing living
paycheck to paycheck the rise of credit
card debt and it's just continuing to
live on the edge on the edge On The Edge
on the edge of the edge and all these
people are saying don't live on this
don't live on the edge there you go do
the boring stuff it works that puts us
out of the Ramsey Show in the books
thanks Rachel Cruz Austin Ben Zach
Andrew James and will everybody in the
booth thank you the booth dudes that
puts this hour in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]